essentially the shadow is the part of
you that you don't want other people to
know about right it's the sort of
conglomeration of your insecurities your
fears uh your perceived inferiorities
and generally speaking those
those parts of you because they are
parts of you were created when you felt
betrayed as a kid or you felt abandoned
or you felt abused or you felt neglected
or you were bullied at school you know
for the way your body looked or uh for
being stupid or whatever the case may be
and so we all have these parts to us
that we don't want other people to know
about and then we have parts to us which
I'm going to avoid talking a little bit
about right now that we don't want to
see
right so there's parts of us that we
don't know about that we're like oh I
don't even want to see that [__] right
so where do we begin well the easiest
place the easiest place and and maybe
I'll just say one more thing about it
um before I just sort of give you the
the access point
the reason why the shadow is so
important is because this is the
psychological material that gets in the
way of your goals and your aims and your
trajectory and what you want to build
and what you want to create and the type
of relationships that you want to have
the shadow is the part of you that
sabotages that that gets in the way he's
like no you don't deserve that now
you're not worthy Or Nah you should stay
up until three o'clock in the morning
and get your faced and you know show up
to that that big presentation with that
important meeting with that client
hungover as hell right so the shadow is
that part of you and there's a a great
American therapist named Francis Weller
who says your pain has its own
intelligence your pain has its own
intelligence right so our work and this
I tell this to men all the time our work
is to start to face our pain right I the
first line of my book is a man's work
begins in pain so we have to begin to
start to understand what is that what is
the intelligence of our pain trying to
say what is it trying to communicate and
where is it already expressing itself in
our life you know because if we can
start to pay attention to that then we
can get a sense of what's happening
within us right so okay with all that
said when we do this we begin to reclaim
these parts of us right in mythology you
see people enter into the cave face the
dragon reclaim the gold right so when
you do Shadow work you enter in the cave
you face the dragon your insecurities
your inner critic right that judgmental
voice is just constantly [__] talking
you
um and you reclaim the gold so that part
of you gets to have a place within your
inner Kingdom where you're not at odds
with it you're not fighting it you
actually have built some kind of a
relationship with it so where we see it
is within what what Jung called our
reactivity so anytime that you become
reactive or AKA defensive critical of
somebody else judgmental of somebody
else shutting down right avoiding a
conversation that reactivity is a big
neon sign yeah pointing towards your
Shadow saying hey I'm acting from my
pain from my hurt from this part of me
that I my insecurities right you might
have probably felt your Shadow if you've
ever been in a relationship where all of
a sudden you found yourself like you
know needy is all hell stage five
Klinger texting the other person
constantly you know it's like okay I
know I just texted them six times in a
row and I know I probably shouldn't do
this again but I'm going to text them
anyway even though they haven't
responded right uh so that's the shadow
right it's like I feel unworthy I feel
needy
um and I I don't feel worthy of this
person's love and care and attention so
that reactivity is what we need to start
to pay attention to that's the access
point okay
so what I usually say is
don't react regulate and respond don't
react regulate and respond and all that
means is that
there's a I'll just bring in a great
author Victor Frankel wrote man search
for meaning he said between stimulus and
response there's a pause when we are
acting from our reactivity it's largely
unconscious we are not pausing right
we're not noticing what we're feeling or
experiencing and for the most part we're
not even
um consciously
deciding whether what we're saying to
that other person is uh congruent or in
Integrity for us right we're just
reacting screw you how could you you
know why don't you you always you never
and we are communicating from this very
unconscious place it's why when you hear
people say like oh I just lost it you
know in that argument I just lost it
it's like well what did you lose what
did you lose in that moment right it's
like no you lost your Consciousness
right and you lost your conscious
capacity to respond
to that other person in a healthy
grounded way
how do we catch it
yes so so very I'm going to give you
four steps okay because people love
their their bullet points and their
steps hell yeah we do it's just it's
very helpful right it's very very
helpful so the the very first step that
we need to become uh aware of is we need
to get familiar with the signs familiar
with the signs that we are being
reactive so we need to get familiar with
the physical signs what does that
reactivity feel like in the body you
know when you're getting angry this is
some work here for everyone but
especially for men I feel like to like
actually feel things viscerally to feel
where it hits in the body and what's
happening with your heart rate what's
happening with your 10 how tense are you
with your stomach feel like what does
your chest feel like why do you feel
like that's so important having maybe
been on the other side I think it is the
ultimate lie detector I think that your
mind can lie to you but your body
doesn't very true what's it like to be
around a man who is disconnected from
what his body he's experiencing
like if he's like I'm not angry and
you're feeling like his body's just
emanating anger what's that like
it's a wall
it feels like a wall it feels like
there's no way to get through that
because there's dissonance around the
truth and always trying to get around it
somehow some way not listening to not
listening to their body not feeling
their body and matching that up with
something vulnerable like it lacks
vulnerability because usually behind
that body is the feeling is a truth
that's usually people I feel like aren't
actually like mad at you they're
triggered into an emotion because of
something that happened to them in their
past so it's like you're part of it but
it's not really about you mm-hmm
yeah so it's harder to trust them yeah
right it's harder to trust them it's
hard to really trust a person who is
saying one thing rationally or
intellectually but their body is
emitting a very different truth right
and so so we have to get clear on what
the signs are especially physically it's
just like okay when I feel anger what
does that feel like you know for me the
analogy I always give is I'll start to
feel a little bit of fire in my belly
and then at some point it's almost like
the for people I've seen Iron Man he's
got that like energy piece in his chest
that sort of like lights up it's like
there's a point where I just feel that
come online I feel a huge intensity in
my chest and then it starts to you know
Bubble Up and so generally speaking for
most men when that energy of their anger
gets into their head is when it's it's
lost right so we have to be able to pay
attention to the energy in the body
first what we're experiencing what we're
feeling so we have to get clear on the
signs physically but we also have to get
clear on the signs uh verbally what does
it sound like when you're reactive you
know do you get louder do you hear
yourself saying certain things do you
hear yourself complaining about this you
know the same thing over and over again
do you hear yourself uh using what we
call universals right you always you
never right which are these sort of
absolute statements about how the other
person is acting do you catch yourself
being very critical of the person so get
clear on what the signs are
when you are reactive and if you really
aren't too sure you know obviously you
start physically but inquire with people
that you trust you know it's like when I
get reactive when I'm angry when I'm
disconnected I'm shutting down what does
it look like what does it sound like to
you and what does it feel like to you
and your body and that'll give you some
Clues as to what it looks like and what
it sounds like and then what it feels
like to to be around you so that's
number one number two is to just name it
out loud right just say I'm being
reactive right or I'm being angry or I'm
being aggressive or I'm being critical
right whatever it is that you're
actually being in that moment from
reactivity because ownership the first
one is awareness right getting very
clear on what you're feeling and then
the second one is ownership right so
naming it out loud and then third say
what you're actually feeling so
for most of us in almost every single
moment what we're actually experiencing
is not the anger it's something
underneath right we were embarrassed we
were ashamed we were sad we felt lonely
right we've we felt disappointed
whatever it is right and so what I say
in the book is that it's easier for a
man to say [__] you than it is to say
I'm hurt
it just is so much easier right and I
felt that in my own life it's so much
easier for me to say [__] you to the
world or Society or my partner or my
friends or my family than it is to say
[__] that hurt you know that really hurt
what you did what you said you know
forgetting to call me or for whatever it
is that hurt me and so we have to
practice being strong enough to say that
hurt me I didn't like that you know so
the third step say where you're actually
feeling and then lastly
shift the attention from your mind into
your body shift your cognition to
sensation physically so Einstein had a
great quote he said the the rational
mind is a faithful servant and the
intuitive mind is a sacred gift but
we've created a culture that honors the
servant the rational mind and has
forgotten about the gift
and we as men have been brought up in
this culture
um right or wrong that over indexes the
rational mind that tells us that the
rational mind is going to solve every
single problem in our life and so that's
the tool that we deploy whenever
something's going wrong but the very
simple truth is that your rational mind
cannot solve emotional problems it
cannot solve emotional equations so when
you're dealing with an emotional
challenge in your relationship your
rational minds are very limited to
figure it out very very limited so if
you can't speak the language of emotion
then you can't feel the energy of that
in your body you're stunted in Your
Capacity to move you or the relationship
through that problem that's happening
whether it's something that's happening
within your sex life or your finances in
the relationship or whatever the
disagreement is so we have to be willing
to move into the realm of sensation can
I be with the heat of the anger can I be
with the weight of the sadness can I
move my mind literally out of my
rational thoughts how do I fix this how
do I solve this how do I figure out what
she needs into what am I experiencing
right now in this moment if you like
this clip and
and sewed click at the bottom of your
screen